and now Tim Dylan is going to have
[Music]
welcome to Tim Dylan's going to hell
everybody we are back on the porch we
are doing video for the people that
asked if we were a few people said are
you no longer doing video no we are
doing video Devin castas with us nice to
be here again yeah we are on video now I
know that a few episodes were not on
video and many of you got angry about
that you know as as I often rage and a
free product I often get really angry at
the samples that I'm handed at Trader
Joe's for not being exactly what I want
this isn't hot actually
what is this free this isn't hot I don't
like it I don't get why do people need
to watch the pod I get it because some
people actually put it on a big TV Wow
like they'll you know they'll put it on
Instagram story and then I'm just
yelling in your home which I guess is
great yeah and people love it
people want people are visual people
yeah yeah you know yeah like like when
kids were stupid when I grew up instead
of just going there slow they'd be like
they're visual learners right right they
they can't listen to you yeah they have
to be shown it yeah with like a play
yeah you gotta put on a play to get and
then of course you know we realized oh
those kids have undiagnosed problems
yeah they have disorders that should
have been identified early in life you
know yeah um well what a fun world we're
living in if somebody came to you three
years ago and said Gary Busey will be
President and people will be attacking
each other in the street with big Mack
they would have been so close yeah to
where we are like they would have been a
little one dimension off yeah where we
are yeah we've got Trump and we've got
milkshakes and now people are debating
do the milkshakes have cement yeah in
them and they have dried cement acid
burning off rifle races yes is have the
milk of course in this fat country it's
a desert revolution
you know the anti-fascists are chucking
brownies at the Nazis that's how you
know a lot of this is [ __ ] yeah
they don't even believe if they're Nazis
I'm gonna get in trouble for this but if
they're Nazis kill them right you don't
think they're Nazis yeah
you're throwing milkshakes - never in
history yeah did throwing a milkshake do
anything right you don't believe they're
Nazis
yeah that's number one I don't believe
anybody truly believes there's gay Asian
journalist who wrote some articles that
people didn't like is a Nazi all of
these people think they're in a movie
but what they think this guy could to
treat him like that to beat the [ __ ] out
of them in the middle of the street they
have to believe the guys Adolf Hitler
yeah they have to really believe or he's
going to help the next date of it like
they're they fancy themselves as
characters in a movie but what they
don't realize is like everyone in the
movie can't be the villain like the
villain can't be every single print
everyone in Narnia was not the white
witch right it wasn't the way that it
worked like there's a villain and people
around that villain yeah but not every
human being you don't like is the symbol
of ultimate evil yeah you know yeah had
you seen anything about this like on
Twitter there's a lot of people like
defending it yeah yeah yeah did this
Andina go yeah
nazi Mullen was funny Nick Bolen was
like I don't know if I can say his last
name what I know yeah I just saw that he
was getting attacked and thrown [ __ ] at
all of these people their first tweet is
like and
is the racist anti-muslim blah blah blah
and then their second tweet is like and
I abhor violence I will say that that I
abhor violence I would never
yeah encourage violence but for my first
tweet in the Strad I would like to point
out everything wrong with this man who's
bleeding on the floor let's just let
that out right now here are my problems
with the victim can you imagine any
other situation oh you know what I mean
yeah a rape victim well let me tell you
about Tasha she was a little stupid we
go home with these boys late at night
she was no Jackie Kennedy
I'll set now I abhor rape do not support
rape do not like right yes exactly you
know but I will tell you this Tasha man
would she just get in the [ __ ] car
with anybody that [ __ ] had it comment
if anyone had it coming it was her tweet
number two
listen consent is real and I abhor and I
i disavow any rape but let me just get
four or five things out did I feel about
Tasha dude who is he he's a gay Asian
guy and he's like a like like a no no
he's one of these guys that he writes
for kula i don't i looked into some of
the things that he did listen the guy is
allowed to be wrong right he's allowed
to write things you don't like yeah I
don't understand
at what point a switch was flipped in
people's head where they were like I can
no longer exist on the same planet
mm-hmm with a human being who was wrong
yeah I mean I don't listen I haven't
read all of his articles supposedly uh
he made a list of journalists and gave
it to Adam Waffen Adam orphans like a
neo-nazi group in Europe okay so they're
all like well this is justified cuz he's
endangering us blah blah blah I did not
look into that I do not have that do not
send me information on that
I don't care please don't send me like a
[ __ ] right actually you know I don't
care I'm not for people getting attacked
brutalized in the street that you don't
like or that you disagree with it is
this does not where do you think this
leads do these people think that
conservatives eventually don't just
bring guns to these rallies is that's
the next step
yeah is more violence right now it's
it's not that funny because people are
getting hurt but it's kind of funny yeah
because it's milk [ __ ] though it's still
funny the next step which would be Syria
isn't funny like there's no persuading
in Syria about the gas attacks and how
funny they are you know but there's no
blue checks in Syria being like lol like
being deeply ironic about watching their
kids you know take some gas to the face
from [ __ ] whoever's doing that yeah
using it as an opportunity
humor is less of a way to combat things
in Venezuela it doesn't really affect
any about like right if if it goes
beyond this to where it's full-scale
real issues I think the government just
comes in and shuts down the party yeah
which i think is what will happen anyway
yeah and my my little conspiracy mind
goes off and goes there's probably FBI
agents in the alt-right and an aunt
afire and in any anti any serious
anti-government movement in the last 50
years has had FBI people from Quintel
Pro every single one has had FBI agents
that were stirring the pot that were you
know basically trying to foment this
type of chaotic these type of events I'm
not saying this is what happened here
but what it does is it discredits any of
these movements
I mean Black Panthers whatever they are
you bring in a few guys from the feds
who like it's not enough we got to do
more right we got to go a hundred you
know and then P you start losing the
country people like well wait a minute
this seems a bit odd yeah but I mean
it's it's bananas discussing this with
people because you're like okay riddle
me this
go attack and again not saying to do
this but it wouldn't it make more sense
to attack ice right hmm Yeah right
exactly they think every one of these
journalists they throw a milkshake at
like a kid gets released from a cage
these are also the people that
supposedly care about the poor and and
these kids in the camps bring the
milkshakes to the kids the kids would
like a milkshake if I was in a I'm not
even in a cage and I would like a
milkshake
I can imagine if I was in a cage which
I'm against don't start with me and
somebody handed me a milkshake through
the bars right I would be pretty happy
that you didn't waste a milkshake on
some [ __ ] guy that wrote an article
you didn't [ __ ] like it you're
throwing away perfectly good food you
could give to the poor of Portland yeah
you know or some white people in a
failed band or whether it was ever
really struggling over there important
yeah but so the these again are like all
these you start to realize that some
people just want some type of civil war
mm-hmm they they have meaningless lives
and the oh and they fetishize violence
because it's it's not real violence it's
kind of this violence that is controlled
to a degree um because it's again it's
not like all-out open total war it's
like here's a journalist that we can
pummel right and or here's some proud
boys that we get in a scuffle or
whatever yeah and these people I think
they just they think they're part of
this revolutionary struggle yeah they're
really not because nobody cares but
looking an uber to the revolution yes of
course ridiculous is taking it over to
the revolution but it just it speak
insanity yeah
today on Twitter people like you see a
guy making milkshakes and people go
what's on the bucket that's a warning on
the bucket what milkshake ingredient has
a warning on
there's some other guy on Twitter goes
hey that's just a warning for the bucket
it says a kid could fall in that bucket
they close up and he's like there's no
cement in that they're just making a
milkshake and I'm like if these people
were actually motivated to do good they
could do good right yeah like if they
actually wanted to do something good
yeah they all show up they can make a
lot of milkshakes how about making
sandwiches and distributing them to
people that don't have them yeah I bet
like nobody does that if you suggest to
any of these people that they show up to
a homeless shelter or soup kitchen they
look at you like you're out of your mind
yeah they're like what are you talking
about I just want to go slap up a
journalist to protect everybody from
Hitler you're like what are you even
talking about yeah what are you even
saying I want to go we'll burn down some
new condo development to fight
gentrification okay have you ever helped
anyone in your own family or a friend is
hurting there like what yeah it's hard
to take these people seriously uh it's
very difficult and here's and by the way
I am concerned that like Trump Trump is
is abyss a boy that like like when he's
in there with kim jeong-hoon and they're
getting along real well
that worries me yeah it doesn't worry
his supporters they think it's great
right they think it's phenomenal yeah
yeah that kim jeong-hoon
a guy who tortured that poor kid otto
warmbier remember that guy hmm I don't
want be a was this guy who supposedly
was on some school trip or whatever and
he likes stole a flag as a joke in North
Korea oh right yeah I heard about those
than all these people on Twitter or like
well that's white male privilege youth
stupid white bet like he's being
tortured yeah in a labor camp and
they're like well that's what you got
you're just going around White's planing
and right white male privilege and man
splint and it's like where's your
humanity now all of those people have
rediscovered Otto because now they're
all like why is Trump sitting our test
the guy who murdered otto warmbier
course said oh but you didn't care
whatever was further right whatever
works but when I see Trump with that I'm
like guys this guy is a guy with
authoritarian impulses he is a
kleptocrat he's got his family in
positions of power I mean [ __ ] Ivanka
and Jared it's who day and kousei
Hussein in there running around moral
Agha
yeah she's running around Europe trying
to get in like a coffee clutch with like
Merkel and Theresa May she's like get
here buddy here's here's what we think
they're like who's this [ __ ] right
who's this [ __ ] okay he's so when I see
this stuff going crazy in the streets
I'm like we we could slide very easy
into fascism real fascism
you know the boot people this country
would learn to love the boot they would
love the boot on their neck because if
this [ __ ] keeps happening
a guy like Trump Trump is is empowered
by all of the stuff like when when these
people go and attack a journalist
because Trump appeals to a few groups of
people but one of them they're people
that want to be kept safe right from
immigrants from criminals from whoever
so when Trump goes hey hey we're gonna
secure this country but here's how we're
gonna do it we're gonna take the boot
and step on your face there's a lot of
people whose country that it'll sing god
bless america
while it and they can card everyone off
to camp they don't care there's people
out there that don't care that the kids
are in a concentration comes talk about
the other night I'm like this can't be
the best way mm-hmm put him in a
Marriott do you know I was in Saint
Louis there's hotel after hotel no one's
staying in there and the people that are
won't notice put them there right put
them in st. Louis they'll leave and I
start team believe st. Louis yeah I mean
there's got to be a better ways it's not
a good way it wasn't good when Obama
it it's not good this is a problem but
people don't seem to understand why a
guy like Trump when you when he came out
were you like were you one of these
people who were like oh he could never
win or well what did you think about it
when he came out yeah that he could
never win at the beginning yeah you're
in LA elitist yes yeah yeah that's
mostly why you know and you're and you
go out with a Muslim woman yes I do
I do I'm dating a Muslim woman so do
that what you will folks by who's got a
very white name I know he's got the
whitest name yeah she's got like a world
war two nurse name it's the craziest
thing it's all I'm not gonna say her
name but it's almost like Doris yeah it
doesn't make any it's like what meet my
Iranian friend or what the [ __ ] is this
man is she [ __ ] assimilating huh yeah
yeah meet my Persian friend what's her
name Mary Sue what but like I could see
very easily us just just right going
right into fascism and and and what's
scary about that is it a lot of people's
country don't give a [ __ ] so I don't I'm
not one of these people that don't I do
think there's major concerns but I don't
think smacking up an demon to go or no
or however you say his name is the way
to yeah yeah I don't think beating up
people that right like you know BuzzFeed
on easy to be Trump you just need an
adult you just need an adult that goes
guys the people that are really
supporting Trump are like people that
are live-streaming from their basement
and talking about Flat Earth yeah and
that the moon is a spaceship that's a
huge contingent of his base and you
can't beat them you've forgotten how to
beat them I mean it's great it's like a
kid who's taking over the house at nine
years old
yeah who's like the parents don't know
what to do yeah they're like what are we
gonna do with
I don't know cut is why fight lockup in
the room snotted these aren't great
political thinkers yeah it should be
away yeah to beat beats it's not with
these random acts of violence that it
then make people think Oh Trump is like
the savior I was thinking about like I
was I was i watch that documentary on
Netflix the UM the Trump did you see the
Trump documentary and it's all about him
in New York City in the 70s 80s and 90s
and really great yeah any at the end of
it and it leaves off right like the last
line of it is he's like they're all
laughing they won't be laughing if I'm
president yeah and then it's boom but
the last part of it is the apprentice
and you realize how much reality
television is deeply affected our entire
culture because it was one of the first
things that people instinctively knew
was fake but they didn't care like they
knew that it wasn't real that it was
completely manufactured reality but they
enjoyed it and they emotionally invested
in it as if it were real right and it
was wild
the original fake news the original fake
news I mean it was wild walk because
people knew some shows were better at
hiding it than others like the raw
competition shows I think had more
elements of things that were actually
real right but even there there were
things happening behind the scenes but
then you got to like these Real
Housewives shows that are all
essentially almost scripted like these
people are put in situation's the
outcomes are somewhat predetermined they
want certain things to happen right and
people don't care they still watch them
yeah they still just go okay you know
red yeah and so it was that and then
when you look at social media those are
the two biggest forces that have changed
culture in my lifetime like I haven't
seen I'm talking about just changing the
way that people act the way that they
relate to each other the way that they
consume like process information on
reality TV
Media he's the monster that combines
both of those things yeah and he becomes
his unbeatable force
yeah he just doesn't play fair which is
like perfect yeah well it's not only
that he doesn't play fair but it's also
like you can't beat him on his turf you
have to move him you can't fight like
all these one-eyed Gavin on and I mean
Gavin had a good conversation I know
people got mad people like you know the
idly it was a little long the [ __ ]
beginning it was a lot I repeated myself
that was good though but and the people
like nobody who likes you needs this and
I'm like you don't know who likes you
don't know who's out there
right I have friends that are angry that
I had the guy are on it called me I had
people that were like messaging me you
people don't know but of course I have
some guy you know messaging me standing
in his backyard and a [ __ ] white hood
being like I didn't need that just get
into the interview he's like lighting
across the interview I just don't need
all this exposition upfront you just
light it you know and he's like he's
spray-painting of the swastika on a
synagogue just typing a comment by the
way I thought it was a little gratuitous
those first 12 minutes but people were
like oh you didn't call and not a lot of
people they were like oh you didn't call
Gavin on staff and whatever and I
thought like I expressed my opinion but
like well people don't realize my
interviews is it's really not your job
to say your opinion right I do that
every day or in most like you get an
hour of it a week yeah my job is to say
what is your opinion yeah like what is
your opinion yeah and a lot of people
loved Gavin and I thought he I thought
he made sense but there were people that
were like oh you know what I felt he was
a little discombobulated I felt some of
what he said didn't make as much sense
which fine maybe maybe they were
predisposed to feeling that maybe not
but by the way that's what happens when
somebody talks and there are people to
feel that way about me and it's just you
let people talk and then there are they
have the ability to
potentially advance their [ __ ] cause
or to hang themselves or did go
somewhere in between but like if you
keep fighting somebody and they're in
this defensive posture and they're just
responding to you they're actually and
at a sizable advantage right because
they never have to explain their ideas
yeah they just have to say while you're
full of [ __ ]
and that's always easier to do so he's
easier to poke holes than to present
some that's why conspiracies are so
great right cuz you get something wrong
with this story I don't buy that what do
you mean I don't understand plane took
off it what that cell phone wouldn't
work at that funk or whatever and then
you're like alright so what do you think
happen and you go I don't know and I've
been in that situation million times I
have to tell somebody I don't know
because it's harder right takes more
work so yeah let them drown themselves
basically if he's wrong he'll sound
wrong it's you don't have to and that's
the thing with Trump like towards the
end of the election people like what's
your plan for health care and he's like
we're gonna have the best health care
system and they were like what all right
he's like we're gonna have the most
spectacular system and that I remember
even some of my like hardcore Trump
supporter friends were coming you know I
don't really know about if he knows what
he's doing
yeah cuz they had figured out like that
was the that was what they should have
done from the beginning just be like by
the way what is your plan right and his
plan was nothing he's been in office for
three years there's not one brick of
that wall built now not one there's more
immigrants coming over the border now
than ever that tax bill [ __ ] everybody
except the walton family that owns
Walmart that's the only people that are
happy with that tax by the way you can't
write off if I go to write off an uber
they cut my hand off so who is that for
who is that for no health insurance is
[ __ ] you're supposedly black
unemployment is up which I'm sure
Trump's some orders are all luck they
all love that that was the best thing
about this race they pretended to care
about black people yeah oh these
Republicans will I've won at what about
blacks we can't we can't we need blacks
to do well we bring in too many
immigrants the blacks aren't doing well
I'm like hey guys
hun care about this was literally fifty
years ago were you've literally stood in
between yeah black people and any type
of justice you've stood in between them
with literal dogs and fire hoses and now
they're like well black unemployment
it's like oh this is kind of rich yeah
it's kind of red
that's all thing when people like Oh
Trump's I don't think Trump's racist
it's like well your then yours kind of
stupid like I can't see an argument that
a guy like Trump wouldn't be racist I
mean what what is the argument that a
guy like Trump what like with all the
things you know about him he said you
know I don't want black people on the
casino floor handling my mic yeah I
don't want them living in the apartment
but like what what exactly do you think
you think Trump was like a big
progressive read in the 70s and 80s one
like racism was just the way it all
worked you think Trump was like a black
guy flag-burning hippie yeah there was
like no the system man we need more
affordable housing ya know he wanted the
Central Park five to be killed he wanted
killed he built gaudy palaces for
criminals I think they even asked them
now but like now that you know they're
innocent would you still say the same
yeah yeah yeah yeah why not why not yeah
I mean dude built gaudy palaces for a
[ __ ] which is fine it is what it is
everybody we have talked at length about
the importance of having a website it is
something that I think is essential for
people no matter how worthless you are
no matter how worthless your product is
no matter how much talent you lack
it's a great place to put all of it it
doesn't matter if you're good or bad
this society is no longer run according
to that little nas acts put a song on
tick tock is like this goofy song and
now he's a millionaire now he's gay all
of these great things
why because was the song good did anyone
enjoy it was it a joke were we making
fun of it or were we really enjoying it
it doesn't really matter does it matter
did the cat did the mouse eat the snake
or did the snake eat the mouse er it
doesn't even matter anymore it doesn't
matter nobody gives a [ __ ]
nobody cares nothing is real do you
understand me it doesn't matter anymore
trying to be good at something is stupid
and it makes you stupid
be loud be an animal be brash be corrupt
be a demon from Hell but have a website
okay and if you do have a website I
think you should use Wix because it's
very easy with Wix you can start from
scratch or choose from over 500 stunning
templates Wix has the most innovative
draw dragon to drop [ __ ] Wix has the
most innovative drag-and-drop website
builder so you can easily customize your
site you can add text images videos
whatever you want you can even build
your site using Wix Adi artificial
design intelligence okay
we built Tim Dylan's going to hell calm
using Wix it was incredibly easy to do
you can check out past episodes of the
podcast maybe had tickets to my upcoming
shows right on the site Tim Dylan D il L
ons going to hell calm using Wix okay go
there scroll to the link at the bottom
it will give you 10% off any premium
plan and let's stress this again we are
now in a cycle
where talent is irrelevant
um
[Music]
hard work
whatever subjective what do you what are
you really doing are you working hard is
that Instagram influence you're working
hard maybe who knows
doesn't matter all these objective
truths that you you you've attached
yourself to have been rendered
meaningless you know Donald Trump a game
show host is the president of this
country the Kardashians are the most
recognizable American family bad baby
little zan and Billy Eilish are the
greatest artists of our time
if Baywatch was remade today it would be
morbidly obese paraplegic lifeguards
trying to wheel themselves down the
beach into the water okay it's all
happening folks everything you're afraid
of everything you love it's all
happening and none of it matters
coz the reality of the situation is you
just need a website don't think too much
about everything else abandon your
friends and family run into the ocean it
doesn't matter who gives a [ __ ] abandon
your principles turn your back on God
but for the love of God or whatever go
to Wix
if you 10% off a premium [ __ ] plan
stop looking for truth stop looking for
good bad is good now bad is good make a
song that sounds like [ __ ] you're gonna
be a millionaire tell a joke that's not
funny you'll have 15 specials be the
opposite you want to be thin be really
fat do you want to be fat be really thin
be a joke don't try to make them we're
living in the time of the joke not the
people who make them this is the time of
the huckster the con artists
the snake oil salesman okay the cult
leader the liar cheat a thief this is
their time and maybe it's always been
there
but is certainly their time now so go to
Wix build a website
and going go on that journey
go down that road yeah go meet the devil
and realize not only is he real
but he's the only one who loves you
wix.com folks is crazy I was in st.
Louis over the weekend and a uh what's
great about the Midwest they don't even
know how they feel politically they just
know they're done you know what I mean
like they know they're kind of done
right they're just watching the rest of
the country like a television show yeah
at this point yeah and just eating
frozen custard smoking a Marlboro red
and waiting for sweet Jesus to pick up
everybody on that boat and take him up
because they know they don't even have
strong opinions they're just kind of
like right after the show and by the way
I'm in their st. Louis funny but at a
great time thanks to all you people who
came out it was a good time st. Louis
itself a little underwhelming as a city
to be honest um well there's not a ton
to know hide some ribs at poppy
smokehouse somebody's like you shouldn't
go into Poppy's you should have went hey
shut up shut up no one gives a [ __ ]
about your smoked pig and where it's
better than where it no one cares you
you should have went to it Poppy's is in
the back half of this place is boarded
up when you're talking about baked beans
no poppies is the good one the good one
is there's people giving birth on the
street in East st. Louis the ribs have a
bulletproof vest on Yeah right right
there's rows and rows of uninhabited
condemned buildings who gives a [ __ ] if
I went to the third-best rib place okay
get some [ __ ] priorities over there
oh man you [ __ ] up you should have
went so a woman came to the first show
on Thursday night and was like I'm a big
fan I love you I love Rick hump because
I'm one of Raycom seven patreon
subscribers so I'm like okay this woman
is plugged in yeah she's plugged in but
she looks she was
pretty and she was like older I couldn't
really tell her age cuz she was like
kind of ethnically ambiguous and she was
fifty years old um to two girls very
pretty husband beautiful home
nice car yeah I'm like wow you know a
real person well but then you always I'm
always scared right because they're fans
of mine ready right so the best thing
ever
a girl message man Instagram no I'll
talk about this other latex I did have a
great time with her a girl message me on
Instagram wants cuz listen my boyfriend
is gonna be in the city we're gonna take
him out for his birthday and it would be
really great if you could just show up
and have dessert with us at the
restaurant I'll pay you a few hundred
bucks make his night he's a huge fan of
the podcast it was right on the way to
the stand I was doing a spot at like
10:30 I was meeting them at like 9:00
9:30 it was literally I just say no
would have been dick yeah everything
aligned the stars are aligned for me to
go to this thing right so I show up and
it's a beautiful they're a really
nice-looking couple they're young mmm
beautiful dinner beautiful restaurant I
walk in you see his face he's like
really surprised and kind of shocked you
know yeah I sit down with them he goes
hey man this is crazy wild thank you for
coming and then he introduces me you
know to the girlfriend and who I know
kind of because she messaged me but he's
like this is whatever I forgot her name
and then he just sits there and they're
both like young professionals
good-looking you know yeah and then he
looks at me and then it goes okay
now tell her how the clintons [ __ ] kids
so I was like dead serious dead serious
not a joke was it funny he wasn't trying
to be funny right he's like did not tell
her the Clintons [ __ ] kids tell her yeah
and I'm like so I'm eating like dessert
and I'm like well I don't know if it's
the Clintons but there are human
trafficking I'm literally I'm like
people in positions of power and I'm
eating
you know yeah so you don't know who's
showing up you know what version okay
you don't know who's coming you don't
know who's coming you see somebody in a
suit and a good look yeah so this lady I
was really cool though she drove me
around st. Louis she showed me the rich
areas and we drove through the [ __ ]
country club and the you know every city
is kind of the same you have the
beautiful leafy green areas the country
clubs the big houses she's like one of
these guys you know invented the patent
on the pop-up thing for the Pillsbury
cinnamon rolls like whatever fascinating
um great and they're all millionaires
and then they call it and st. Louis I
think they called the Delmont divide or
something like that and here's one
Street where you cross over it and then
you were in post-apocalyptic as the
great as Chris Hedges would say the
great Chris Hedges a sacrifice zone yeah
well you don't see anything
it's just boarded up houses you see
people um it doesn't seem like there's a
ton of services you don't really see
even a lot of urgent cares you wonder
what happens if somebody gets sick you
don't see a lot of police and we're also
20 minutes away from Ferguson oh that
whole thing that whole event yeah I get
into BER from the airport and I said to
the uber driver I said where do you live
she said Ferguson I was like okay I just
put my head I'm like well let's just
have a quiet ride yeah let's you know
because quite frankly I just don't need
to get I don't even you know yeah she
was like that whole thing never happened
you know and I was like well okay I
don't even know what that means and I'm
sure it didn't happen the way that
everyone thought it happened because
nobody was there
right median flames whatever but I would
feel a lot better if I could just listen
to Liz oh and stare out the window and
you know enjoy the scenery which by the
way that Liz Oh performance on the
Beatty Music Awards was so [ __ ] good
oh yes I clip of it oh she's killer yeah
and first of all what is who is Billy
Eilish I have no clue this girl is
clearly an MKULTRA vet she every video
she's like bleeding out of her eyes
there
like rituals I'm not even that guy yeah
they come out even that guy that's like
look at the symbolism why is Taylor
Swift you know right you know in a fire
what does that mean why is Haiti Perry
in hell in this video but like you look
at the Billy Eilish video and it's like
these weird rape fantasies come to life
she's bleeding on every horse of orifice
like this blue black blood what the [ __ ]
is going on like I don't want to seem
unhappy I don't want to seem uncool cuz
I want to be you know woman forward
Satan forward but what the [ __ ] going
on yeah
what is happening I don't know play the
girl has the energy of somebody that
Harvey Weinstein kept in a cage and
raped for ten years and everyone thinks
it's great yeah she's on Ellis she
doesn't even sing she's just mommer's
she's like little kids these little kids
are like thinking it's great yeah I like
Billy I want to get raped into Fame come
on come on I'm a bad guy come and get me
yeah mr. senator mr. studio head come
and find me put me in the middle of his
pentagram and introduce me to the dark
lord I will be impregnated with Satan
and then there it's like what is this
yeah and by the way that's amazing about
black versus white when you're black
like Liz oh she's up there she's a big
girl she's singing dancing and playing a
[ __ ] fluid yeah this chick just shut
up and went I love Satan and they're
like gasps patch millionaire yeah
millionaire yeah Liz owes been singing
for like years and years and years
this one just shows up like she was
wandering down a highway with blood all
over her like she just escaped the shed
and true detective
and then she's you know and she's on the
view
yeah and I you know I don't want to
sound unhip and uncool because I don't
get what's clearly something's wrong
yeah something's wrong there Billy's not
gonna I don't think Billy's even gonna
make it to Amy Winehouse I like it's a
problem something's going on
yeah I don't want to seem maybe I'm
wrong
have you seen her I've seen his pictures
ever yeah she looks like little Zane but
like a girl she looks like little Zab
but she little zen I get a wholesome
about nice tattoos I get a wholesome
vibe from little Xan here like I don't
think little Xan could spell Satan right
so I think he's kind of like a teddy
bear he's a lovable man zan just wants a
pharmaceutical yeah a bag of cheetos and
like a soft chair to like slink in and
like make noises that are kind of words
right well he's like you're laymen you
know a lady you like you know yeah like
that's what I think yeah I don't know I
don't get the dark vibe from Jean I mean
it is I guess dark in the sense that he
can barely speak or move most times I
see him but that's the kids that's the
kids nowadays you can't you don't want
to start like a Boomer respect these
kids I know you have to like everything
you have to like everything that
children do yeah yeah you have to let
children lead the way even if they're
clearly on drugs you have to a person
being violently raped yeah by members of
the music industry they should still
lead the way yeah what is the kit what
are the kids think about global warming
come here
yeah blinky blinky the autistic yeah
rapper what do you think well you know
Planet [ __ ] you have to call myself an
old-timer if you're like 27 or like hey
I don't know about this young generation
I'm seven oh my
aah people people think I'm in my 30s
and I keep telling people I'm [ __ ] 18
and they don't believe me because the
[ __ ] stupid I just graduated a school
ok
I just graduated [ __ ] high school and
it was a [ __ ] dope year and I went to
the prom with Billy Eilish and we we we
caught a baby out of some woman's womb
in the problem it was a prank it was a
prank whatever but like the head of
Capitol Records or whatever Capitol
Records is now was there and he made us
do it and then he hid the baby and I
don't know he kept talking about you
know the one true forced it animates all
things darkness
whatever prey but the prom was fun you
know
we listen to me ghost we listen to cardi
B you know we had a great time Drake
Johnny Ghosh's blood yeah
Johnny Gosch Devon gosh not Gauche dose
means something's like passe like it's
not cool anymore
johnny is gauche Johnny go [ __ ] I mean
what you feel like when you posted the
when Louie came out and you got some
flak you're right bad comics Louie Louie
came out at skank fest it was awesome
and raped three women and this is a
story that no one has heard um and and I
Louie we got on stage it was a woman in
the front row he lunged it or any bitter
neck and everyone laughed yeah and then
he brutally raped he brutally raped her
and then was click cheering and whooping
it up yeah and then then guys were
actually throwing their girlfriends at
Louie going rape her rape her and they
were filming it yeah and the girls were
into it at first but then it was weird
yeah but I just fell
art is very complex Sam yeah and I
wasn't prepared for all of the raping
that happened mm-hmm he didn't do any
comedy that was the misnomer he did not
he did not tell any joke there's a story
going around that he got up at a comedy
festival a whole group of people was
happy to see him he did 15 to 20 minutes
of really funny material and then left
and everyone felt safe and happy that is
actually not the correct story
yeah no the correct stories that he
brutally raped multiple women in the
audience while doing know comedy
whatsoever right and was paid four
million dollars to do that by the white
male in Turkey which is now a LLC mm-hmm
and no listen I was at Mohegan Sun Louie
was this gang fast I was watching that
intro man it was [ __ ] cool and I did
it this is the coolest moment of the
last year people don't really know what
cool is because I didn't say like this
is the greatest thing for women you know
not that it's I think a what like
negative thing but like people reacted
like I said he should run for president
right what I said was it was cool that
one of the greatest comics that's ever
lived popped up and did a sat and an
underground completely DIY
do-it-yourself fest of all yeah and that
nobody gives a [ __ ] every woman there
was happy with it they were all on their
feet applauding everybody was excited
the staff of the venue was excited even
though they [ __ ] reversed that
position because they're [ __ ] liars
um and everybody was cool with it and I
tweeted out and then a lot of people got
mad at me which is okay here's the other
thing yeah great good hey man I don't
I don't I'm not one of these people
where I'm like you don't have a right to
say that I'm an [ __ ] or an idiot or
that I suck or whatever say whatever you
want it doesn't unaffected um but just
know just know and this is the game you
are very very bad at this you're very
very bad you might be right about some
of the things you believe in politically
culturally I don't know but here's what
I know you are horrible
you you're really really not good at
making people laugh yeah and part of
your anger part of your rage comes from
that now there are other people that are
funny that I disagree with there's a lot
of people that are great that I wouldn't
see on Iowa but there's a lot of people
out there that are like garbage yeah and
have never met anyone laughs and I've
never made a [ __ ] dollar yeah doing
it and they are enraged that people have
an audience
mm-hmm and it doesn't matter if they're
in the writers room make it 5 grand a
week they're enraged that people show up
and laugh at other because nobody got in
this for money
yeah most of these [ __ ] had it anyway
so you think you give these people money
would shut them up satiate them that's
not the case they desperately want
people to tell them how great they are
they want people to laugh and it and but
they don't put the work in they're
actually a lot of them are very lazy
yeah and they're they're like
fundamentalist the good comedy doesn't
[ __ ] come from you being right all
the time right yeah you know they're
threatened by like a natural talent
they're threatened by anybody that's
threatened by an unnatural talent yeah
they're threatened by a dog who's
getting attention in a park I mean these
people are here I mean don't see these
shows that they put on in Brooklyn
they've all got costumes on it should be
better I'm like this should be better
you all have class tombs on yeah
you're like trying this should be good
why is it so bad why is it like worse
than a play that kids and a family put
on while everyone gets ready for dessert
are you all on drugs did nobody practice
do you lack inspiration what is bad why
I wanted to be better yeah I don't care
there's people that are very funny the
trans comedian Patti Harrison very very
funny
I don't know her we don't we don't talk
we don't hang out I'm not against that
she may be but let's say we would have a
lunch I would imagine that we might
disagree on a point or two I don't know
I'm guessing but she's incredibly funny
that's the reality um but a lot of
people are or not but there are people
that are funny and I'm like [ __ ] it cool
yeah but people say to me like like
what's the point what are we doing with
the loot no one cares it's a fake issue
it's a non [ __ ] issue
yeah people want to see him he's gonna
perform it if people wanted to see you
you could perform people barely want to
see me I perform I don't give him a
choice you lock the doors I show up I
show up I'm on the road in these [ __ ]
shitty little towns not always some of
them are great but none of these people
Dan Soder said something wants I don't
forget he might have been quoting
somebody but he said all of these guys
have never lost a fight and now they all
want to be the champion mmm this is the
problem this is a group of people in
comedy who've heard the word yes over
and over again and it's traditionally a
business where you like no no no
rejection you get a thick skin you get
licked off you don't care yeah these
people here yes all the time so they
can't hand
doll when anything goes the other way
there's lost you know yeah I think they
want comedies who remain as mediocre as
their contributions as well it's these
are people who think that throwing
milkshakes at people is gonna bring
about the revolution it's the same
mentality of like your unserious you're
not a serious person if these are the
things you believe mm-hmm
you know mm-hmm but I don't have a prop
I like a lot of people are like Oh Tim
Dylan's in LA he's gonna sell out yes
correct correct I'm here I am here and I
have my [ __ ]
gaping wide open frame multinational
corporation to mount me and [ __ ] me lay
eggs in me that will give birth to an
army that will murder your families
here's the problem no one's doing that
I'm just here with my ass open and
nobody's mounting me not one I'm ready I
keep telling them my life for you what
am i you know
I'll feed Billy Eilish every day in her
cage I'll look after her I mean you know
I'm selling out you're putting wigs on
at a garage ranting this is a dumb nail
this is how dumb people are but let him
think let it out sighs yeah I am putting
wigs on in a garage but that's that's
the future the future ain't Netflix put
wigs on in a garage all these young
comedians like when you go on the road
they'll tell you they're gonna move to
New York or LA and like if they had a
real comedy nerd there that you're
opening for they could really you know
me I don't give a [ __ ] yeah and they're
all like I just want to move here I'm
gonna get real good and I'm gonna move
to New York and make poppy real proud
and I'm like great where's Taco Bell
have a Taco Bell here good good do that
do all that ha just wanna get owns it
show great great where's that custard
place can we go there
can we go there please have quiet on the
way one guy sweet guy be telling me he's
like 31 he's icky I'm gonna move soon
I'm like that wait wait wait you're only
31 you're a baby it's what we need do
you know yeah I don't know ma'am
we're in trouble as a country folks you
know there's a lotta there's a lot of
people in this world that are good at
things you know there are people that
are people that are great deal makers
and make deals there's people that are
great athletes they just have a you know
fundamental you know maybe genetic
advantage I don't want to say that I
don't want to go down that road I'm just
saying not genetic maybe but they work
hard at being an athlete I'm not saying
that race informs your ability my point
is this okay there's a lot of people out
there that are good at different [ __ ]
okay some people are good cooks you go
over their house to make you good apple
pie to make a nice pie not not those are
infrequent now but and some people are
lovers they're they're they're they're
[ __ ] they [ __ ] they know how to [ __ ]
I have a friend like that he just [ __ ]
what he does he [ __ ] you know and he's
what he does puts his dick so he's hard
puts it in and out of a vagina and then
he ejaculate s-- and though the woman is
pleasured as well hopefully that's what
he's into what a lot of people are into
but some people are into it more than
others some people direct their flaccid
dick they watch porn 5 hours a day
they've never met another human being
some people are you know
part of multinational pedophile rings
these are problems big problems in the
world okay dad some people are in a
bestiality okay I am NOT and I do not
support that although there are some
animals where you go do they really care
yeah there are some animals that clearly
don't care you know what I mean and may
even be in you know what I mean but an
animal can't consent that's the argument
I'm against BC Allen I want to say that
this is not this is not a pro bestiality
ad night we've gotten off on a real
tangen ear I'm not saying you should
ever [ __ ] an animal but if you would
[ __ ] animal would you ever want to do
it with a soft dick because an animal
would notice that you were not fully
hard so if you are [ __ ] animals and
you don't have a hard deck maybe go with
premise it it's perfect for any man who
wants to last longer in bed or wherever
many of the men let's be honest many of
the men do not last long enough with
their partner to have an orgasm it's not
because they aren't man enough that kind
of is but it really comes down to
science on average men taking about five
and a half minutes to reach climax where
a woman takes around 18 minutes okay how
long does a Shiba Inu take anyway
permits it was Davitt soul jokes folks
it's jokes comedy comedies coming for
you per mess it was developed by doctors
to help bridge this orgasm gap its [ __ ]
spray folks what it is okay you spray it
on your dick in your heart go to delay
spray calm if you use the promo code Tim
15 you'll get 50% off your purchase
delays very calm they gave it all to us
at gas digital we all sprayed our [ __ ]
we're walking around bumping into each
other it really does work your [ __ ]
stays hard stays hard when it's very
important it's very important because
you want to find someone to marry and if
you're a man you want to find a woman
and display your sexual prowess and [ __ ]
you know better than adequately you want
to do it really well
so that she marries you and overlooks
your lack of employment the fact you
really aren't a great dad
you don't really have any emotional
security you'll probably cheat on her
you don't have any morals you're kind of
bankrupt in that department you're not
really the person that she can count on
for anything you just kind of go down to
the bar and you like drinking with your
friends you're kind of a frat boy even
though you're in your mid-30s you're not
good to your children or your wife you
make comments about other women in
public it's actually disgusting many of
the parents at your son's school if
lodged complaints about you you see your
wife suspects that you're using drugs
maybe even selling them to children in
the neighborhood you're kind of creepy
you keep making comments about your high
school son's girlfriend and that's
creeping a lot of people out you're just
one of those guys but why did she marry
you because you had a hard dick and you
trapped her okay she didn't see who you
for what you really were which a dirty
old man lazy bum that never brought
anything to the table that was you know
content with just really floating around
the margins of society and you just got
by because you were [ __ ] white you're
always [ __ ] white and you just
[ __ ] lounged around and you took the
family on one vacation at Disneyworld
you stayed in a shitty hotel it wasn't
even on the property you screamed at
your wife in front of the characters
your kids were embarrassed they started
crying you got in their face and you
were like be happy we're at [ __ ]
death the world you started shaking your
son
your wife said stop it stop touching AB
and just for a moment you know she just
wished that in that moment you just died
that something snapped in your head and
that you dropped dead right on the floor
and she never wished for anything harder
in her life and she closed her eyes and
she just wished that the last thing she
saw was you fell down in front of the
Magic Kingdom [ __ ] massive stroke
aneurysm hemorrhage whatever and you
were just out and dead and that she
would go to your funeral and she would
cry tears of happiness but she would
disguise them and that she was upset but
she wasn't she was so thrilled that you
were dead now she could go find another
man a real man maybe she wouldn't think
too much about his [ __ ] [ __ ] she
would pay attention to more than that ok
but you didn't die you didn't die she
closed her eyes and she prayed as hard
as she couldn't when she open those eyes
you were standing there and you looked
more alive than ever and she was trapped
and she knew it and how did she get
trapped because before you went on that
day he sprayed some pur messing on your
[ __ ] and she said this man is hard and I
bet that means he's gonna be a good man
and she was wrong but
you gonna live Space Mountain and it's
the dark and you like to touch in the
dark
and she's worried and you're worried you
don't know what you'll do go to delay
spray calm folks de la y SP ra y dot-com
the show is good people like in we're
gonna be independent soon we're gonna
set up a patreon we're gonna still do
ads the ads are gonna still be very
funny it's still gonna be the best
caliber of products [ __ ] spray CBD wicks
you know we bring you a suicide
prevention online suicide counseling
things that we feel that this audience
could really benefit no tax preparation
or any of that we know you people are
okay shout out to that lady in st. Louis
who took me out that was really cool she
took me to a really cool place called
olio in st. Louis fun little restaurant
go there you took me to a great
restaurant what was that call hex tax
hex French restaurant neco Park how good
was that is great love that place maybe
dumb name but it is a dumb name but it's
the it sounds like a road been some kid
message man Instagram that he went to
school with what's his name Cactus Jack
Daniels yeah you want me to tell you so
been told a story about a guy that he
went to school with him cactus Jack's
office before that guy he died right I
mean yeah you have to Cactus Jack will
get your heart attack I mean I'm trying
to find this guy I gotta find this guy
he did though he like he [ __ ] and this
guy how did he die again Ben I was an
aneurysm I feel bad like wasn't even his
fault
Jesus was he a good kid that's
still friends with his family you never
knew his family else you just full of
[ __ ] huh he was a good child good boy
I can't Cactus Jack somebody somebody
what what school did you guys go to
what's it called
Jim Ned high school named Jim Ned Oh a
Native American named Jim Ned I love the
day a Native American sold out his tribe
and you guys named a high school after
him in Tuscola Texas cuz he sold it out
for the white man
great great can I sell out gays I hope
the Family Research Council names and
building after me who was Tim why are we
going to Tim Dillon's Christian High
School well during the Great War
Dylan turned informed on all the people
who wouldn't message him back on Grindr
and they were slaughtered so he sold out
his community and that's why we named a
high school after him he was a good man
thank you Tim um how long have we done
so far Ben yeah we still got a little
time here folks there's one more thing I
wanted to get into I think we got into a
lot at Billy I said I got me some people
people will be angry but it's a fact
something's wrong it's a problem um I I
don't want to seem like a [ __ ] all the
time about people in the service
industry uh-huh
okay and I know that I have before yeah
um and I think that the major
distinction between me and other people
out there is that I see people in the
service industry as people so I expect
them to behave and and to be the best
they can be and if they're not the best
they can be
I have to I have to rein them in yeah
and
let them know that they can be better
let them know that they have to believe
in themselves right and sometimes I have
to do that sternly sometimes I have to
kind of forcefully give them a pep talk
because they've lost all faith in
themselves right sometimes I'll see a
waitress who's forgotten a side of honey
mustard that I had ordered 14 minutes
ago and I've said she has forgotten how
great she could be I gotta get her over
here
and really let her know yeah that she
could be a lot better than she's being
right now right and sometimes you know
people say oh you catch more flies with
honey than you do with vinegar I've
never believed that I think you catch a
lot of flies
if you throw acid at them and even if
you don't catch them they they will they
wake the [ __ ] up yeah dang I'm not
looking to catch the Flies I want the
Flies to know that there's a problem but
I didn't do anything here's my thing
what happened here's my thing I'm gonna
be honest and there's a lot of waiters
out there and servers that might
disagree with me and listen again I am
NOT here all I'm here to do is to love
you right that's what I'm here to do I
love you
the people that don't yell at you don't
love you the people that it cuz I always
dip I tip you but sometimes you gotta
have a talk because I don't know what's
happening man appetizer has a [ __ ]
meaning appetizer look it up then what
does appetizer say get-get the
definition up and get the definition of
appetizer up because there's confusion a
small dish of food taken before the main
course of the meal
the operative word there is before the
appetizer comes out before the entree
yeah okay sorry to think it showed up
here's one reason why because if you go
out to eat alone
and you want you don't want two plates
on the table at the same time to make
you look like you're a fat pig you want
to eat one plate and then get rid of it
and then have them bring the next plate
so that nobody knows that you even had
the first play it's God now there's no
evidence you don't just start throwing
plates at the table like this is a mess
hall and we're all eatin quick before we
go back out to war you bring the
appetizer first I don't care what the
kitchens doing control the [ __ ]
kitchen don't fire up the entree until
you see me eating the appetizer do not
put the I don't care if it's a diner
it's not my fault you work in a [ __ ]
diner you orthopedic shoe wearing [ __ ]
and this isn't even this is an old girl
of swingers with a full sleeve of
tattoos whose real [ __ ] hip who I
gave a dollar to and I didn't say
anything to her the swingers probably
got back as smiles I got back there I
backed him but I'm only sitting outside
him I'm kind of only allowed to be
outside I can't eat in the restaurant
curbside for you because of the problems
that I've had that we've described on
this show which again are me expecting
the most out of people I love those are
the problem yeah those are the problem
that's the issue it's a problem you're
not looking at a segment of humanity no
[ __ ] them I don't they're they're
roaches it's looking at people going
you're human being deal with me like a
person deal with me what if I was Christ
what if I was Jesus Christ what if Jesus
Christ walked into this [ __ ]
restaurant and said I want to sit at the
big booth no it's [ __ ] here I know
that it's reserved for six people
they're not coming here your food sucks
no one's here people get tricked into
coming to this dumb restaurant where
people sit here all coked out licking a
grapefruit pretending at somebody's ass
all this isn't a culinary experience
it's dumb kids and old queens I know
what this [ __ ] place is let me sit in
the big booth you can't what if I was
Jesus having that moment would you would
you shun me and turn me away would you
or would you [ __ ] say thank you
Christ for a very hundred assessment of
this restaurant God Christ this is
pretty good you you you call us out
right on the nut little on the nose
Christ when I said that to them when I
said just coked-out people licking a
grapefruit like an [ __ ] somebody
should go ah god that's pretty on the
nose Christ and you sit in that booth
what I'm trying to say is that when I
order a quesadilla and then and then a
open-faced turkey sandwich these are not
to be delivered at the same time they're
radically different they don't
complement each other at all
I'm double-fisting guacamole and gravy
in front of people at 9:30 in the
morning sitting on the sidewalk because
I'm not allowed in the restaurant so
what I'm saying is that when you write
this order in just communicate with the
kitchen a little bit yeah okay just
communicate with the kitchen you know
I'm not gonna do anything
Kayson he was on the appetizer menu yes
that's yeah yeah big my said thank you
and I said I said to her I said you know
everyone in LA you know I think there's
[ __ ] cool you just go for respect I
just want the kids respect I want
crack the food is that the food is like
bad it's like you don't even understand
why it's so bad like why
is quesadilla gross yeah I can make it
in my house right it's like the easier
how was it so bad so I'm there I just
want I just go there because I go I want
this to work I want this to work and I'm
sitting outside and uh you know so
nobody's in there - that's the other
thing you know you could it just
couldn't been thank God cuz you know I'm
there and I it's not like I belong in a
[ __ ] environment with winners but God
is that not the case
you know these are just old dilapidated
West Hollywood rats you know yeah and
they're sitting there people who might
have been the [ __ ] like 94 just old
freckled big titted goons these la guys
whose brains have melted they're sitting
there these people with their shitty
little dogs dumb tourists yeah because
it just says Hollywood diner they think
it's you know right and I just said
there I go can you bring the quesadilla
first and she came to the table and she
had two plates in her hand one of them
was a quesadilla and one of them was the
open-faced turkey sandwich which she
didn't have mashed potatoes so she
brought a basket of fries so now we have
three plates on the table two plates and
a basket and I'm there alone I just got
off a four hour flight and I have two
plates of food and a basket of french
fries and I'm sitting there and
everyone's looking at me like oh look a
pig has come to the feast okay because
this [ __ ] couldn't have been discreet
throw the fries on the plate you don't
have to bring a basket yeah up front so
now I'm sitting there and I said to her
I go I wanted the quesadilla first and
then she goes oh what are you first of
all what the [ __ ] do you mean oh it's a
[ __ ] appetizer do you not understand
this
sequence of the way you're supposed to
bring these things out here should I hit
you with a chair I'm not saying I should
but I'm I'm asking I'm asking that what
what should I do
now I because I'm a gentleman okay I
said it's fine it's fine
hmm it's fine you sacrifice for her
mistake I sacrifice I said it's fine she
said is it I said yes
well now it is so that I just ate my
Thanksgiving dinner of food whack Amole
gravy french fries yeah it's a good
Cologne on the sidewalk outside a
restaurant then I'm I don't know that
I'm banned but I'm not welcome you know
what I mean like yeah I'm not welcome
but I don't I don't know again I don't
know what my next move is with that
place here's a few things I'm
considering do I call the health
department and maybe let them know some
of the things that I've observed
that's an idea I'm not saying I would do
this I'm I don't know where I'm I do I
do that do I call up and order food to
be picked up and then no one picks it up
and I do that once a day yeah
for the rest of my life until they
change their policy like until they're
like we no longer have pickup right you
have to give us a credit card number and
then I just keep getting Berner credit
cards and burner phones do I have them
caterer a white pride event do I
organize a neo-nazi event and have them
unbeknownst to them do I plan another
Charlotte cell and have them do all of
the catering for it is this the way to
handle it and then have them have to get
out and disavow and I mean not cease for
rebellion SS shields Klan robes eating
their food going this is kind of good
these vegan banana pancakes are pretty
good Heil Hitler
is that the move right is that the route
I don't know or do I just keep going
back until they figure it out did you
have a talk with the waitress he's like
he said I didn't because I don't believe
that anything I said I tipped her eight
dollars on a $35 bill which is a lot of
money and the reason I tipped her that
money was because I felt bad for her and
I said here's a woman who's working
really really hard and doing a horrible
job and she's probably living in LA
and she's under the impression that one
day someone's gonna give a [ __ ] about
her band or somebody's gonna you know
you know option her screenplay or she's
gonna get cast on a reality show she's
gonna be the fun-loving tattooed girl
that everybody dumps loads and and she
gets like ten grand a night to appear at
a club in Atlantic City and stand there
in a VIP section while like you know
Mongoloids from the Jersey Shore look
[Music]
but none of that will probably happen
that's all best case right yeah what
will probably happen is she'll get older
and older the tattoos
that once made so much sense on her arms
will make less and less sense because
she'll be shooting heroin and her veins
will be bulging she'll be shooting
heroin because she just started snorting
it and eventually it was more
cost-effective to shoot
she'll be squatting in a friend's house
just long enough until her friend gets
arrested and the cops drag her out
she'll have long since lost her job at
that diner she'll be sleeping in an
abandoned car and selling her [ __ ] on
the street and I imagine his businessmen
dumped loads in her and then shoot her
up and she sits there waiting to die she
feels that cold black goo running
through her veins
she just closes her eyes and she wonders
what Wednesday night she's gonna meet
God at least she'll know least she'll
know that years and years ago a fat
[ __ ] saw this all happening he chose
not to tell her instead he chose to give
her eight dollars which he now probably
[ __ ] shoves in her ass and keeps her
emergency money but I didn't tell her
any of this I just said thanks a lot see
you soon tibula comedy calm I am coming
to wise guys in Salt Lake City Utah
Friday and Saturday might miss that cuz
it's coming out Sunday I'm also going to
be at hilarities in Cleveland on July
19th to 20th American comedy cohan San
Diego August 1st through the 3rd I'm
coming to zany's in Nashville in August
I'm coming to [ __ ] the stardome in
Hoover Alabama stand-up live in
Huntsville Alabama I'm coming to the
comedy zone in Charlotte South Carolina
no North Carolina
Charleston Charlotte I think it's
Charlotte anyway come out tickets are on
my website Tim Dylan comedy calm I post
all the links you'll see all the links
closer to the dates on social media but
if you want to get them now go grab them
on the website I am doing that southern
run it's gonna be a lot it's gonna be a
lot of fun people tell me you're coming
back to Chicago you're coming to Atlanta
in the fall we're lining up those gigs
now in Chicago Atlanta you know maybe
back to Texas some other cool [ __ ] going
on in the fall and it'll be a lot of fun
I'm at the Comedy Store this week a few
times and and The Improv my kill Tony
tomorrow well yesterday you'll get this
on Tuesday so but get some tickets folks
like the podcast subscribe to us on
Apple podcasts we're growing it's fun we
got a lot of stuff coming down the pike
soon new videos patreon is gonna come
we're gonna go to twice a week cool
people that are coming on to interview
we're going the whole route here we are
gonna be independent very soon love
everyone against digital will still be
there when I'm in New York I'll still be
doing all of their shows Metzker just
signed on there that's gonna be [ __ ]
great
and I'll be doing all of those shows
when I'm back in New York but we're
going independent we might start live
streaming to YouTube gonna do a lot of
[ __ ] playing around a lot of different
ideas I love the idea of a morning show
once a week I don't know how we could do
that at swingers well I just love the
idea of like a coffee morning show where
we all have coffee we livestream in the
[ __ ] morning we're [ __ ] around man
with a lot of different ideas so when
the patreon gets here if you guys can
support it great if you can't just tell
your friends about the show if you like
it tell them to listen to it tell them
to subscribe to it that's the most
important thing anyway to be honest
obviously support the show if you can
but the most important thing is that it
grows so tell people about it
Devin where can they find you
youtube.com slash Devin Casta dvan
Co sta and I have a podcast hate that
you love it with Devin cost on iTunes
hey do you love it is about [ __ ] Devin
is a
comedian it is Kevin Devin is gay Muslim
Ben our producer is trans youth transia
and that that again is why I hired him